le vaccin il est pour quand alors je me
tourne vers christophe prudhomme vers
philippe douste-blazy alors il ya 198
candidat vaccin il y en a dix qui sont
en essai clinique c'est-à-dire vraiment
phase iii s'est on peut penser qu'il ya
deux phases et faut rappeler philippe
passé sa vie on en prend un c'est sur
les volontaires sains ensuite les phases
2 pour commencer regarder si une
différence chez des gens qui ont reçu le
vaccin par rapport à ceux qui n'ont pas
reçu la phase 3 c sur les dizaines de
milliers de personnes donc actuellement
il y a dix candidats vaccins sur des
dizaines de milliers de personnes et on
regarde si ceux qui ont le vaccin sont
moins infectées que les autres l'om
estime qu'à 50% de moins c'est efficace
moi personnellement je pense que demain
moi je suis extrêmement suis pas sûr
qu'on trouve un vaccin parce que on
connaît on connais pas du tout cette
maladie encore sur le côté immunologique
on le connaît très mal par contre ce que
je crois c'est qu'il est possible demain
de savoir par un test qui va faire une
forme sévère et qui ne va pas l'accord
ça c'est important ce qu'il y ait des
gens atteint 55 ans 40 ans que se
retrouva sur messiaen comprends pas
pourquoi on m'a dit une info voilà je
suis pas si elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut je
joue je vous le demande je vous pose la
question parce qu'il ya trois labos
apparemment qui sont en stade 3 au
niveau du vaccin après on passe au stade
iv mais après il faudrait même sa face
même là c'est à dire que c'est encore un
nom au minimum un an au minimum 12 mois
y est enfin pour moi j'estime que c'est
d'ici un an ce serait mais un vaccin
thérapeutique c'est à dire sur celui qui
est un cas extrêmement sévère pouvoir
donner un vaccin c'est pas un vaccin
prophylactique c'est par un vaccin
demandons à toute la population au
milieu à céret uniquement à ceux qui ont
un cas extrêmement sévère par exemple
quelqu'un qui est obèse qui à 75 ans qui
à l'évidence et donc ça peut très mal se
finir
là on lui donne ça et je pense qu'il
peut passer et si on regarde on peut le
relever choper finalement le virus mama
c'est ça oui il y a des cas il y a des
cas aujourd'hui on a vu
vraiment ce que les gens avaient eu un
co vide et trois mois après en prennent
un second est d'ailleurs on trouve qu'il
ya des mutations aussi toute petite deva
riant on va dire qui fait que à un
moment donné on a cru au mois de juillet
qui serait moins virulent est en réalité
celui là actuellement le quatrième est
encore plus virulent alors question
intéressante un de philippe coulon est
ce que l'on peut nous parler de la
troisième vague parce que on va dire
votre livre cartonne maladie française
pandémie et pourtant tout avait été
préparé premier sur amazon le livre de
philippe douste-blazy préface du
professeur didier raoult
vous savez j'ai toujours défendu le
professeur didier raoult je connais pas
mais qui aime bien voilà je trompe pas
ce qu'il m'a apporté beaucoup d'espoir
pendant le confinement et j'aime bien le
personnage et je trouve qu'il apporte
des réponses
il avait dit néanmoins tu aurais pas
deuxième vague je me rappelle d'une
interview voit que intéressant si vous
voulez exactement c'est que au fond la
question c'est pas c'est une une seule
question est ce que nous sommes capables
de dépister massivement une population
si nous sommes capables de dépister
massivement une population avec des
résultats en moins de 24 heures bien
évidemment on va voir tout de suite le
cas précoce a donc ciblé le cas précoce
immédiatement vous en occuper par
exemple vous savez avec un petit
appareil qui vaut 20 euros dès l'instant
où vous savez que vous êtes positif
moi personnellement je me prendrai ce à
trois fois par jour je regarderai la
saturation en oxygène ma saturation la
vôtre aujourd'hui celle de nous tous est
à 99% de cette maladie de temps en temps
vous pouvez passer à 95 sans vous en
rendre compte
simplement sauf si vous le mesurer c'est
ça donc ce qu'a fait le professeur raoul
et ce tous ceux qui s'occupent vraiment
de ces malades
au début ils voient que la saturation
commence à baisser et il leur donne de
l'oxygène tout de suite ça ça vous
empêche d'aller en réanimation
si vous ne savez pas si vous êtes chez
vous tranquille au moment vous commencez
à être essoufflée là vous allez voir
qu'ils avaient un risque d'allergies
sont rassurés